hi this is Tom Rhodes please join me as
I scour the four corners of the earth to
bring you interesting and intelligent
funny people who will enrich your life
with wisdom and laughter I'll take you
to Europe Australia all over America I
might take you to the peaks of Machu
Picchu the canals of Amsterdam the Great
Wall of China or the swamps of Florida
and certainly the many many comedy clubs
and comedy theaters all over the world
come hang out with me and meet the many
interesting people that pop up in my
life as I travel the world as a stand-up
comedian you're listening to Dumbo a
radio gotta kick baby
welcome to Tom Rhodes radio thank you
for listening today's guest is Ron White
Ron White is one of my favorite
comedians and for very personal reasons
I started out being a stand-up comedian
on the southern circuits in the United
States as did ron white he's a guy I've
heard his name forever we did the same
clubs and you know I I think I love ron
white because I know how hard he worked
to get to where he is today do you hear
the lightning that's the comedy gods
approving of this episode you know when
I had Jim Gaffigan on this podcast the
most beautiful thing he said he said
this thing about carrot top whenever he
hears people talking bad about carrot
top he feels like someone's insulting
his family that comedy and comedians are
his family and I know a lot of comedians
don't feel that way but I kind of always
felt like it was a fraternal Brotherhood
even with women and just everyone in the
world who can be a stand-up comedian all
that matters is if you're a good
comedian or not it doesn't matter if
you're black or white or gay or straight
or wherever you're from so
the comedy gods still approve of this
introduction so Ron White for me kinda
also gives me inspiration that an older
comedian who works his ass off can still
bust the lid off of the roof of show
business and make it the way he's made
it he slept in rest areas and in cars
and all the horrendous things that so
many other comedians have to endure and
now he's selling out massive theaters I
love to hear him talk about his private
jet you know Ron does a line where he
says most companies in the world are
getting rid of their private jets for
economical reasons and he said he's I'm
gonna keep flying mine straight into
bankruptcy and he said him one day he's
going to live in a mobile home trailer
and have his private jet parked out
front with weeds growing up around the
edges I just loved that vision and you
know me personally if I get stinkin rich
i'd probably get a canal house in
amsterdam and a castle in Spain but
anyway Ron owning his private jet is
just something that makes me very happy
as a brother comedy warrior now I had
met Ron White for two minutes two years
ago well first of all let me say that
you know I was always a snob I never
liked Vegas I never wanted to play Vegas
I always thought the comedians that
played Las Vegas were like the comedians
that played cruise ships I wanted
nothing to do with it so only in the
last few years at playing in brad
garrett's comedy club at the MGM I have
I really started to love Las Vegas
there's great restaurants there's great
shows going on and there's great
comedians performing all over the city
it's not the old hockey mother-in-law
joke comedian Vegas of 50 years ago
things are definitely cool and happening
there so I had never met Ron White even
though we have many mutual friends and i
was at brad garrett's comedy club at the
MGM two years ago and i was going to the
bathroom he's walking up and he
smokin a cigar and I'm like Ron White
hey my god it's so nice to finally meet
you and I said look I'll be right back
he goes in smoking his burning cigar and
they kicked him out because you can't
walk into a club even if you're famous
with a burning cigar so he was gone by
the time I got back it was an odd story
we talked about it in this episode later
but I thought my chance at meeting him
was I don't know it was just a wad an
odd occurrence so through mutual friends
Thank You Kathy Nelson who put this
together last month when I was back in
Las Vegas ron was performing at the
Mirage that's right comedy gods I said
the Mirage so my show at the MGM
finishes at nine-thirty I haul ass in my
rent a car to the Mirage and I got to go
backstage and see Ron at the Mirage and
you know from his dressing room to the
side of the stage he's got six security
guys with flashlights it's like the
president with the Secret Service gee I
mean it's already secure we're backstage
at a casino but you know that level of
Fame and comedy it's just titillating to
witness so I got to watch him absolutely
destroy the place for an hour and 45
minutes and then I got to observe him
meeting his fans afterwards and and then
Olivia newton-john the pinnacle of
female beauty once upon a time in mass
media stopped by to say hello to Ron and
to tell him that she was a fan and yes
she still looks stunning into her 60s
and then I got to go into Ron's dressing
room and have this conversation with him
so this is the very first conversation
I've ever had with ron white he's
someone I love and respect and for me
watching Ron White do comedy it's like
watching your favorite sports team that
wins every time because the man never
fails to disappoint and he's got a
hard-hitting jokes and quite frankly
he's kind of one of the men and
comedians I aspire to be because he's
got consistency he's dedicated to it and
his jokes always crunch you right in the
heart of the matter and that is why it
is my pleasure to present to you now the
one and only Ron White
perfect start a great great show tonight
my favorite part of the show walking out
and the sea of people coming out of the
auditorium oh my god he is so funny I
already take six months off you know you
think he really knows dr. Phil it was
like really cool to like just the love
of people and hearing their little
snippets of conversation as they were
leaving the theater man that was really
beautiful yeah that's something that I
won't ever get to experience oh we got
kind of a weird things because I do
these be happy things after the show so
you got to get a little glimpse of how
they feel about it all but outside of
that and you know that being a comic to
that you don't know how they you'll
never see you in on stage and you you
don't you you don't know what they say
when they walk out of one of your shows
yeah but you know granted you are a
solid performer but as a comedian in a
nightclub you know they don't you know
you gotta win them I gotta win them over
every night because like most of the
time they don't know who I am you know I
mean that you got a lot of add your
adoration from these people but on top
of that you're delivering you know
hard-hitting funny [ __ ] well you got ya
day they'll i don't i don't think they I
don't really [ __ ] around to find out
what they let me get away with you know
and I continue to try to produce it you
know so but I don't think they but I i
think if we get south or everything its
weak that they don't go i mean i don't
give me much for very long yeah no I
mean that's where their main bands right
comedians and got to go you got to go do
it you know and if you're going to hang
out at the you know it and then do this
and you have this gig you know with the
mirage in a big room and stuff you
better be you better you better be going
at it yeah you better be working it and
you know it's trying to stay you know
relevant and not read only by relevant
all I mean by relevant is do a new [ __ ]
you know try a new stuff you know how
often do you turn over new stuff because
seemed like they you know there was like
brand new stuff in there uh you know it
depends how old is the Muslim woman with
one I bought the score a month and it
seemed like I've really worked out you
know five minutes bit um okay two months
I don't know all right three years ahead
now I read said it's an is a it's a bit
it's a new bit so it's but it's a you
know they just it's easy to work them
out you know when once you find the
content and so you know that's that's
where you get good at well it seemed
lately because you call back to it you
know you had a lot of callbacks I'm
watching you from backstage which was
great and as a comedian you know you're
like you know like a boxer you work the
body with a ton of like short stuff it
seemed like at the beginning and then at
the end after you've done an hour you
slow down and told some stories you know
so you were hitting them with heavy
artillery at the beginning it seemed
like yeah that whole the whole front end
of that shows not not nine months old
the whole first half hour of it isn't
nine months old never been published in
any way so that and you know I heard an
interesting point that somebody made
about the you know the comedy boom and
then there was kind of a comedy unbound
and people blamed it on different things
but one of the things you and I rode out
the unbound with but one of the things
that I heard somebody say that one of
the reasons it was after I was
interesting was that the guys that were
in the top position the top drawers and
those comedy clubs didn't change their
act so the you know and they didn't the
you know the [ __ ] the love master and
those guys the barrera those guys didn't
change their act today and so people
would come back and it was fantastic
they're great comics but they didn't
move on very well a lot of them didn't
and I'm not saying nun
you know I brought you chastise for even
saying that but but but that's just
report someone made and I thought well
that should be valid because I noticed
some of that myself I was guilty of it
myself you know for when I was just
doing clubs nobody gave a [ __ ] I didn't
have to move on and then put out a
record that took me 16 years throughout
my first record I know the feeling yeah
yeah but I remember when that boom
whatever the is I wouldn't call it a
collapse it was like all the you know
cities had five clubs and then went to
one club the one strong club but I was a
feature act I mean I think we've been no
comment about the same time and you know
I've just missed you everywhere we've
got so many mutual friends and in and we
have similar bad habits and I'm
surprised we never met each other before
but I remember a lot of those headliners
were spoiled making five grand a week
and then when they would stop being sold
out every night they didn't want to go
out for less money and me being a strong
feature act I was in the right position
and you're like going from like 600 a
week to 1,500 a week to headline Jesus
that was a fortune yeah so I was yeah i
was probably i was headlining clubs then
and and but i was a pretty reasonable
headliner that went to a very reasonable
head ladder so i went back to about
1,600 bucks for a period of time but i
just wanted to quit comedy altogether
because i felt like i was a better comic
and I was getting less money and you
know but I went in selling tickets I
mean I just went in selling tickets I
just there was nothing else I can say
and thank you that once they got to the
you're not selling tickets argument I
couldn't say yes I am look at all those
[ __ ] people because they weren't
there you know in austin texas i could
sell 40 you know that was quite a few
that's my [ __ ] deal well i remember
in the 80s they would say you know if
you if you're selling tickets you can
[ __ ] the bosses wife right or you can do
whatever like guys who are like I just
out of control I like to use told that
story about jeff foxworthy and you guys
coming to Vegas you know when things
were starting to pop
that you told the story about plane at
the Riviera and you're like wow man you
know me Ron White I'm at the Riviera you
know like I can totally know this
feeling and you think you're staying at
the Riviera but you're staying at the El
Rancho or Rocco some shitty gig like
that I just watched top five that Chris
Rock movie and there's a scene in there
where like he's partying in Houston just
the it was some sex drug party and like
the the mattress is covered with this
other guys sperm he's like sleeping on
this like tiny corner like all balled up
and it's uh I know so many moments like
that i mean you know what are you hear
what did you hear I mean I like that
what I mean like you know back in the
just being on the road forever and
playing these gloves you know what are
your fondest and strangest memories of
that period oh you know for me it was
you know there was just a period of time
that I was you know that I was a zine
acid and haha [ __ ] you know and going
on stage I was bored wow I was bored and
you know and self-destructive and I
still AM to his death and i was banned
from the [ __ ] punch line in atlanta
for 10 years well for eating acid on New
Year's then not being able to quite
finish it oh yeah because I went on
stage once on mushrooms and I thought it
was hilarious I like to do know what
happened I'll i think i thought i was
very conceptual I thought I mean it's
really good what's right but we made van
me from the club even though I thought
10 years was a little much they you know
they should have it was unprofessional
oh hey what I did was unprofessional I
just how many times did you go on an
acid and what was you know what I hate
this did you get any golden knowledge
nugget I think probably you know I
probably did it was always you know it
was just idea it was just a part of my
period of my life they haven't kind of
in my twins and then in my you know and
then again in my late 30s that I just I
always kind of had a I always liked that
feeling what I used to say was I like to
get too [ __ ] up and then come down a
little bit I don't like to creep up on a
buzz I like to get where I'm just
[ __ ] almost out of control and I way
all right buddies hanging here for a
minute oh he's back into something I can
[ __ ] deal with that so I've always
liked you get too [ __ ] up and then
come down and settle into it that makes
perfect nature ya know because I always
looked at it my dad was the life of the
party my dad always had a cocktail in
his hand my dad loved comedy he's the
reason I'm a comedian it comedy albums
and I've been a heavy drinker my whole
life I busted my head open in
Philadelphia see the scar and I haven't
drank in a year and a half it's been a
new experiment for me no but uh I still
love drinking love everything about it
and partying and I had a there was a
brief couple year period after I had my
sitcom where I was really angry and had
a lot of money and i was living in new
york city and i was doing a lot of
cocaine and I heard Richard Pryor say
that that was he was at felt he was at
his best when he you know doing a little
coke and going on stage for me cocaine
was the worst [ __ ] up the timing yeah
when I was doing it I didn't write any
jokes mouth dry now dry I thought that
was the absolute worst way to be on
stage so I to her all the time I am from
the United States I consider myself a
patriot I met my first wife during the
Vietnam War she's from this quaint
little village outside of penomet in it
but I'm I can never pronounce that word
Ottawa
I love the to hurt my wife I only have
sex with my wife I've been married three
times and that has not always been my
policy but I find a lot of comfort in
having one sex partner because she knows
what I like and I know what she won't do
turns out there's a list she won't do
and the first thing on the list is talk
about the list
it's hard to figure out what to get her
for a birthday last year I got her
something with a cord not good this year
I got her breast implants and I've never
been a big fan of plastic surgery but I
got to admit I've had a lot of fun
playing with these things I haven't
given them to her yet I just keep them
on my tour bus and you rub them in my
face I'm glad they clean up easy
what
I'm just glad they're not made out of
corduroy that's all I'm saying I'd have
to have them scotch guarded
Shh I find it a little ironic that the
product I used to keep from ruining my
sofa should I spill my drink on it is
actually called Scotchgard sometimes
things just work out perfect okay yeah
i'm looking for a product that's gonna
protect myself if I spilled my scotch on
it what do you got
we've got Scotch garden
let's go with that
you got vodka garden
my wife sees a very talented designer we
live in as gigantic house that you guys
bought us and she's really talented but
she can't go to sleep at night let's
every single thing in this gigantic
house is in the exact spot she meant for
it to be now before I married her she
told me she was anal and I was like
great
it turns out there's two kinds of anal
and she's the wrong one
we were watching CNN the other night and
they were doing a story about nasan
about that astronaut lady that went
crazy and tried to kill that other woman
really funny and it wasn't just about
that but it was about NASA and how
they're just not as thorough as you'd
think they would be and they're always
backing up and covering their tracks
which they are and I guess because so
many women are going into outer space
they've just allotted ten million
dollars for a study to see if there are
any dangers in a woman suffering from
pms to have her menstrual cycle it was
ero gravity like hell you other dangers
in a weightless environment the psycho
[ __ ] can fly did you play the coconut
grove improvident i did with Vic Henley
once galoshes we rode out of hurricane a
hurricane that's right that's right
that's right here's guy that I remember
cuz i was there running well i got like
wrote [ __ ] on the walls we're gonna die
I mean this was before Katrina New
Orleans you know they have it was uh
okay and what was it that was a bad yeah
I like white me just stood there there
was [ __ ] debris 20 feet high on both
sides of the street when I [ __ ] clear
the roads that was there like a month
later it looked like that that's right
and the whole city was wrecked the the
club had shut down a thing for three
days and you know I didn't neither one
of us had the money to like you know
skedaddle or whatever and like you just
things are smack and and I'm old friends
with Vic it was a it was a beautiful
bonding experience but I'll never forget
in that you know I'm here we work
together still good idea oh I didn't
know that how you doing but I was with
him we just did the theater at madison
square garden together Wow we've done.we
day he does all my new york stuff with
him so we've done Ashley yeah yeah we
were with him last weekend in salamanca
at some place in Salamanca and Victor's
wonderful yeah he's old great friend of
mine but the
miami condo i'll never forget they had a
there was a pamphlet of all the local
Alcoholics Anonymous meetings in the
Miami greater date it was the schedule
for the AAA meetings and then there was
a cassette tape and there was a title on
it and said his herpes forever so I
thought you know that was really spoke
volumes about the geyser rolling through
there yeah but when I lived in New York
City 98 99 Vic would call me up and say
aim and I've got some pork on the grill
and collard greens and he kept me you
know in southern food and while I was
there so yeah we've we've always enjoyed
each other's company it's a he likes to
get too [ __ ] up and come down a little
bit haha that's not done Victor like to
do there we got thank you lord I can
show it a picture I will if I file get
my phone later it's a picture we're on
the tour bus and it's a Vic his tumbled
down into the well of the bus the stairs
going out of the bus he is tumbled down
it happened in slow motion it was like
oh it's not gonna happen oh it is gonna
happen no it's not gonna happen oh let's
go look it's happening right now oh baby
baby till he fell down all the way to
the bottom of the but only upside and
early upside down on the bottom of feet
up the air just trash we and I'm not
bragging when I say this every I'm not
at all I was shame them we get what we
call bus [ __ ] up so I the bus station
drunk you see people like well so
instead we're driving down the road in
the back of this bus and and we really
have no we've been completely
responsible we have a perfect driver
that's fairly rested and and but it but
really a great driver and all we have to
do stay sober enough to make it to the
beds and that's not very sober so we
just have to see if I wish to their list
of music smoke weed
and write jokes and it's the best time
manse the time I just love as its but
that's my chin and we just but we get
free [ __ ] up there's been a couple
times that we've got some photographs of
me not making it back to the bunk
there's like past a half lengths up to
it only that all that's pretty much it
for tebow that's what you dream of
that's your lens up one moment oh yeah
years ago when i was doing tons of stuff
for Comedy Central i was there boy it
was the beginning they sent me on the
road with the hoarded festival and the
black crowes headlined it I loved the
black crowes and then they were they I
had my own tour bus that went it was
like Ziggy Marley and Sheryl Crow and I
was in the little caravan and you know
butter zone that nothing's better than
that I loved the black crowes and I
finally get to meet Chris Robinson the
singer and he pulls out we're talking
and he pulls out of a bag of mushrooms
and were eating them like potato chips
and we're talking oh my god this is a
guy i love i love his music and i'm
eating mushrooms with him this is gonna
be the best night of my life the
director of the comedy central thing
comes in like 20 minutes it goes we got
to go we're driving on to the next town
so then I get yanked out of this thing
and now I'm on mushrooms the camera guys
and the director they're trying to sleep
on the bus and I talked that drivers ear
off all the waited like you Cleveland
[ __ ] man it's a drag yeah so what I like
the strangest memories of being back on
the road and humping it you take
greyhound buses I tell you the what's
the moment helo vago god damn I'm so
blessed this is uh there it is is it
it's really pretty clear pretty clear I
was going to drive from Arlington Texas
and my little gray Nissan truck too
omaha nebraska and its middle of the
winter and so i started i take off and
in my truck breaks down before i even
get out of 10 so I'm like a [ __ ] so I'm
the middle act they got no money so I
got to take up the i'm on a [ __ ] bus
very [ __ ] blizzard across [ __ ]
Oklahoma and I got no there's no other
way to get to [ __ ] Omaha you have to
go through Oklahoma storm no storm
doesn't [ __ ] matter you got to go
back through there so we get stuck
behind a jackknifed little debbies truck
and I'm hungry ah so this little debbies
truck is jackknifed across the [ __ ]
roasts are crunchy have here the first
vehicle behind it so we're there for
four [ __ ] hours just sitting there on
the side of the [ __ ] road looking at
this little debbie sign and they won't
open it they don't have the keys to it
they're like a club nothing so they
finally move it we can't get around it
you know there's another if we're
wearing a bus you know we're not an
off-road vehicle so they move it so now
I'm four hours late and so I have but
there was a chance I can still be there
maybe by Showtime and so I get to Kansas
City the bus stop and I think well imma
call them let them know so I call and
the girls that answer the phone I said
yeah I listen I'm gonna be laying she
goes you're here next week hahaha
now I called and verified this date with
a girl it worked at that [ __ ] office
and that was so now I got no money to
get back with so I had to talk him into
just let me ride back to where I came
from for [ __ ] nothing like I wanted
to do it you know just a look and then
the next week I drove back in my fixed
little [ __ ] truck and did it again oh
that mean but you know just life on the
[ __ ] Road my choice I chose it over
whatever else you know I chose it over a
lot of things you know I let it be the
priority over of a ton of things in my
life I know the feeling I know so and
this is you know and this is where it
got me or where I'm at so in in its Who
I am so I you know I don't apologize for
it and but I don't think anybody else
was wrong either you know just these are
the decision I made I had so many
relationships ruined destroyed because I
was on the road too much and I always
think now like my wife you know she's
she's in Holland i Skype every day with
her I bought my mom a macbook computer
she's you know she's 76 she ever angry
at her couch i know hahaha i could get
her on here i will wake her up but you
know i always wonder like have what how
many relationships might have worked had
today's technology existed right n 20
years ago ya see my wife is a sleep in
the [ __ ] room so she's here with me
Laura was my wife normally travels with
me all the time you know she went to
visit her family what's uh yeah I mean
that certainly proves you're in a good
relationship if you can travel with
somebody well she's a Margo I don't know
if you know anything about my life
she's a singer songwriter hno yeah she's
a beast just a flat [ __ ] beast she's
a she's a Throwdown [ __ ] vocalist and
is good at grace all right so she has a
hit on the radio now right now number 24
on the Billboard charts Bell
contemporary her thats long as she rides
with john oates what's the Sun it's
called what is the new song that I've
heard on radio yet yeah it was going to
be under heavy my Papa died poppity BLAP
never too late sorry never done anything
there was a way i started this tour this
summer in las vegas and while I was in
Vegas I broke this tooth off at the gum
line in an alcohol swimming pool were
later than sedan
I had a show to do in four hours that
was a drunk and missing a tooth it
looked a little unprofessional not to me
but to the fine folks at the Mirage of
god damn sure did I told him I said you
got to get a dentist to patch this up I
will not go on stage looking like this
because this tooth doesn't look that big
until it's gone they found that all that
dental school this dennis is 14 years
old the uggs be up for the gas and I
don't feel anything I'm like dude you
turn this gas up and he goes there
regulations the state of Nevada state in
which coat one second ball and I asked
him I said where'd you go to college it
goes Brigham Young [ __ ] dude turn it up
to Catholic never let a Mormon say your
buzz level never don't do it
and I'll tell you why they don't
understand [ __ ] up the way you and I
do they don't they're guessing and their
shitty guessers when he got through with
the procedure you can still tell which
tooth he worked on because it was a
different color my teeth look like
Indian corn we have so many mutual
friends but we didn't meet until two
years ago and so you know I've heard a
million stories about you and we played
a lot of the same clubs always wanted to
meet you and I'm at brad garrett's
comedy club at the MGM two years ago and
you come walking up down the aisle oh my
god [ __ ] Ron whites here I finally
get to meet Ron White and hang out with
it I'm going to the bathroom I gotta go
on to headline the show in a minute and
I go Ron nice to meet ya ago I'm going
to the bathroom you know I'll see you in
a minute and so like I go to the
bathroom and I wasn't gone four minutes
and I walked back into the club and
you're gone you'd stormed off you came
in smoking a cigar and brad garrett's
brother God love him nice guy didn't
know who the [ __ ] wrong it was and he
comes up to you and going like get that
cigar out of here you remember this yeah
what if I could believe it so like by
the time I come out of the bathroom you
had already left and I was like [ __ ]
that was my opportunity to to meet him
so how big I don't even know that I
don't know that yeah but Brad asked me
to come over I said well you know I'm
gonna smoke my cigar yeah I'm gonna have
my [ __ ] brand and that's my brain so
he goes okay rod whatever whatever you
want to do so i cant were there any
other they want me over there but so I I
hear d then who I am when I tell him i
said oh no no we're brand invited me
over here he understands with all this
and he goes no you can't smile duty you
can't do it I said okay I'll just let it
go out he'll put it out or get out well
[ __ ] you
then I'll get out so when I left that
was a pity I don't think yeah I don't
think Brad wouldn't let that happen or
anybody I you know what I don't either
right I've been back since I've ever
been ya go now any weapons I was
crestfallen I was like a [ __ ] at the
hell rod it was us you know any waiver
in part of his my ego and I like I
shouldn't who the [ __ ] am I become
smoking a big [ __ ] so y'all are and
if I can on smoking venue it's
unnecessary I have a tendency now not to
do it at all I if it's a binyan less
it's a video I'm just may act I won't
come in there and smoke and I'll drink
on stage but I won't come in there as
well as the guard even though they let
me most of the time I mean I'm you're
almost hundred percent the time they
don't care but right but but if they're
not there to see me then it seems odd to
the people that I'm smoking in there the
people that don't know me you know would
you then most people don't know who I
guess that most people go I like you
told the story about hanging out with
dr. Phil and the you guys are buddies
and stuff my wife studied psychology in
college and so some sometimes like you
know we'll be having a moment or
something to be happening and she'll
like you know break me down
psychologically so does that have him
with dr. Phil like you know he's like
Ron you walking around with your lit
cigar and feel entitled no no you know
dr. Phil not only does he not give
unsolicited advice he doesn't give
solicited advice literally I'm going to
a divorce where I'm just getting get
kicked in the [ __ ] alley by these two
divorce lawyer simultaneously while
they're jacking each other off and it is
killing me as you literally killing me
and I'm playing golf of doc I said I'm
telling him any divorce lawyers god
dammit doctors things just [ __ ] tear
me have I don't know what to do he goes
keep your head still when you putt
hahaha
that's what you're gonna hear heading
better you probably feel better moving
your head that's it not uh oh I'm so
sorry you're going and I don't know if I
can be seen with these Duffy's but he's
had a great guy yeah I really do I'd
mind I think he's funny as [ __ ] I've
turned into he said I don't watch his
show that much but we're but if I don't
flip it through he's a buddy of mine so
I listen to what he's saying inviting I
mean I don't plan it but I watch it was
with lady on his show had a chihuahua
whose feet it never touched the ground
she she took this Chihuahua out of the
Chihuahua nothing at birth and and
claimed that she can telepathically
communicate with this dog and it was the
smartest dog in the history of any
animal in the history of anything dr.
bill goes I guarantee something I'm here
digs up if that dog was on his back
fishing in his own face he wouldn't know
where the fish was coming from
everything so you disagree either I know
you're big reader what what book you
readin no Willie Nelson's uh life the
story the it's a long story so just his
autobiography it's good it's good he's
pretty honest you know it doesn't it
didn't it's almost like Jagger's in
there and they you walk away from
Jagger's autobiography not liking him at
all you know didn't make jacket right
one yeah oh you did the Keith Richards
did nobody booked it they did okay yeah
yeah and but I mean I have you just you
know what Jagger just so arrogant that
he doesn't even see his life story as
something you'd look at it and go well
you're you're you're a total [ __ ] pig
dude I mean you're Divya he doesn't see
it that way
and would buy a van in here if you read
a keith story keeps these books and that
a lot it is a very interesting to read
about because they have so many
similarities I mean from their childhood
almost you know their early adolescence
and when they met I mean all those
stories are good to say you know and
then the stories of when they made those
records and all that stuff's the same
and just some of the background stuff is
different so then but as a history story
they verify each other out that that's
true what they're saying and so but I
walked away from Keith Richards
autobiography thinking more thinking
better about Keith going well this is a
great [ __ ] guy that was really he was
generous in the book about the way you
play guitar and you know secrets and
things that he knew open jeep oeg right
exactly and so and then you know him and
Jagger was just more about al account
and I [ __ ] his wife and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] her and welcome to ass and [ __ ]
her in the mouth with children haha
there was not one moment since that band
first formed that somebody wasn't tongue
in his balls and pop in his mushroom
fine now oh yeah okay keith was whacked
out on heroin for 10 years and then he
came out of him and that's when the you
know struggle in the bad habit what did
you get out of the Willie Nelson book
well I'm not visually but it didn't just
said it really talks about the struggle
I mean they did you know to help you
know he was a great songwriter and but
in Nashville he wanted to be in perform
and but Nashville really doesn't cotton
to see your song writers they like
singers and songwriters they don't look
they don't know how to mix them they
don't want it to be that way they don't
know how to do that that's not how their
system works there are people that are
right songwriters and they get there at
nine o'clock in the morn next arrow five
o'clock meeting and they write saw
they do it in the formula that they know
who died that day makes hits and they're
good attitude and they make gillians of
[ __ ] knowledge and they like seniors
that are off the charts [ __ ] talented
but they don't want to compromise any of
that for somebody that can write a song
or vice versa they want the song writers
writing the songs and the seniors thing
or something some Willie Nelson came
there and he just he was just different
I mean he was just different and you
know but but it also talks about his
background and how he ended up as a
child being a poet and you know just his
background how he dado hello Lionel
added up to him you know how he got to
where he was why he's a [ __ ] it all
added up to Willie Nelson so in that
part of it was very very very [ __ ]
generous to me you know the guy wrote
crazy for [ __ ] it right in and they
were they were saying no you're you're
no good you're no good one of the
greatest songs of all time really even
crazy haha yeah now even crazy it's not
it's not good that nobody's gonna listen
to it because it's not this formula is
so so literally he was at Tootsie's
[ __ ] orchid lounge which is still
there today and that's 60 [ __ ] seven
or whatever it was I don't river and
singing crazy with you just written and
and bassy clients husband was in the
crowd and he comes up to him good you're
coming with me anywhere we go because
we're going to my house thanks you got
to hear this song you go just one thirty
in the morning you gonna be his legal
I'm gonna wake her up you got to hear
well so there ya i said any she they
said it that it started off it wasn't
very good because she tried to sing it
with his phrasing and nobody could sing
like Willie nobody sings with that
[ __ ] jazz phrasing so they had to make
her see it like her before it was great
and then her rendition of it
the best ever you know nothing nothing
can challenge our rendition of it but
and then it was the biggest one of the
biggest selling songs of nazriya country
music what's your favorite Willie Nelson
song great five blue eyes crying in the
rain it's not his song it's not his song
Wow he [ __ ] murders that yeah he does
murder if it's love is you know it's a
covered he didn't do a lot of
conversations with that that wasn't
Islam and the only reason I've noticed
because I'm really ready yeah yeah yeah
anytime even though he talks about all
that stuff angels flying too close to
the ground that is his and that's a
beautiful song there's but he wrote so
many of them for so many of me just song
after song after song that you would
know that he wrote it he was literally
he was seen he tried to sell crazy for a
hundred dollars well and the guy was so
nice and when I'm doing I do this is a
hit song I'm not gonna buy him for a
hundred dollars he'll I need a hundred
dollars I got this song I'll write
another song but it was it was a
struggle for him you know it really
wasn't anyway me and larry the cable guy
did his big EG recalled me to book it
talks in this book about how he started
doing that as a promoter himself and how
he would call the other acts and book
him himself and then one day I get a
[ __ ] phone call it is really Nelson
look at me to do the picnic and then
years later I've read the book and find
out he's calling everybody everyone
gives me and larry the cable guy had a
great lad he said Willie Goblin and
go here this will announce because uh
I'm gonna put you on hold by at Bob
you'll annoy me away what was the wasn't
like because I knows what I was gonna
say was I saw him at the hollywood bowl
once and and then i took a trip to
austin once for the fourth of July
picnic this one was in Fort Worth the
one that I was in later Larry and I did
damn waiting that and it was it was a
cool deal we you know it was blue-collar
just gotten big he and I were both
really really getting really popular and
they were paying it's almost nothing to
do it he goes all right i'm gonna give
you all eight bucks all right like yeah
that's fine I'll do it [ __ ] out I just
want to do it [ __ ] yeah dude so I'm
[ __ ] later and why wouldn't have I
can do it i'm saying though Willie by
smoking a big fat joint I've been
putting John Prine [ __ ] David Allen
toe and what really well I'm having the
time of my goddamn life my life by the
picnic I saw David Allan Coe was there
and I've seen him twice vastly
underrated no [ __ ] on a I'm love
David Allan Coe his bag his big bus is
so [ __ ] amazing because he it's been
his bus for [ __ ] 30 years and so it's
shaped like him you know it it the
chairs that he sits in in his body are
all shaped exactly the same because he
does i need those two hundred Knights
right Pat so and he's got pads and
pencils hanging his memory so bad he has
pads and pencils hanging all over the
bus and then he's got posters hanging
over the window so you there's no light
it and then he's got any figurine or
poster or image of him or records or
anything they've ever sold or stacked up
and it's in and you just rides in the
back of this thing and write songs and
any but if you just walking around only
has to do
just John sup- there's just pads and
pencils hanging from the ceiling just he
goes again I just forget and but but
[ __ ] it on stage ii if i can rocket
looking beat it the [ __ ] I've had a long
ponytail purple this guy's I don't know
how old he is 100 he's such a badass
what is on you [ __ ] Damon Allen
cow Jesus graph the greatest version of
please come to Boston ever he did but
would you lay with me in a field of
stone Jesus right yeah what are you
looking for he needs it you know let's
get some pads and pencils hanging for
this guy in case the lightning strikes
again yeah yeah you know that was just
that wasn't really one of the most
memorable weekends i've ever had you
know i'm just doing willies think so
it's I hope he talks about that weekend
in later in the book because I'm not up
to it yet so I hope he does so cool I
got busted with weed in Florida last
year less than a gram of weed and they
took my happy ass to jail I've been
partying in Florida for years I didn't
even know they had laws look to me like
everybody just run amok down there and
I'll run amok with you I will run the
[ __ ] out of a muck with you they took me
to jail them and I'll tell you what
happened I fired these two pilots for
being [ __ ] and there were such
[ __ ] they started following my
plane around on a software called
flightaware and if you know the tail
number you can follow any player in the
world anywhere it goes and then right
before I'd land in a town they call the
cops tell them as the drug plane so the
cops are come [ __ ] with me that's pretty
[ __ ] funny then they were on the news
in Atlanta where I live both of these
[ __ ] live on the news going Ron
White is out of control he gets drunk on
his plane he smokes pot on his plane he
had sex on his plane I'm like this my
plane we're talking about right
no like I did that [ __ ] on a delta
flight for [ __ ] sake
no my phone's off
my wife got pissed at me when I got
busted with that wiener and she smokes
pot it's the [ __ ] is up with that I come
home she goes you smoke too much pot so
let me get this straight you smoked the
correct amount of pot
you ever smoked so much pot your wife
starts to make sense me either you have
your own tequila out and you mentioned
Larry the Cable Guy you're like the you
know the best-dressed tequila it's like
a high-end product you know larry the
cable guy he's got um and I've know Dan
you know forever we started out in
Florida order same crappy one nighters
he's got his own food products it didn't
for sale in the 99 cent store I'm sure
you haven't spent much time in the 99
cent store but there's a variety of you
there's a variety of products and one of
them is uh is lasagna 99 cent was on
like the lasagna shells and obviously
whoever like signed the check to get all
these food products made must not have
been aware of his [ __ ] lasagna joke this
used a boom okay hearing the really yeah
he's got yeah yeah that's true yeah
there's like a beer bread corn bread uh
and he's got tater chips right and one
of them is tater salad flavored tater
chips well I'm like wow all right we're
gonna quit sending each other Christmas
cards I guess mm-hmm well I like to do
that you talked about Jeff Foxworthy
when like you know the highest selling
album and I remember you know I started
out on the southern circuits and we've
done it forever I remember seeing like
the stand with Jeff's like CDs and your
cassettes like you know that was like
pretty massive for a guy to have his
album being sold in a gas station and
then well they were the Cable guy's got
you know there's get her done hats I
mean that's that's quite a mark on
American society you guys left and you
know what it was and it was all you know
all that came from Jeff's generosity to
share stage with friends you know
because he didn't really need it you
know he had already he was already the
biggest sell comedy act of all time and
was still selling megu just making he's
still making in a hundred thousand
dollars a show and he decides to do this
and you know then the guys are really
benefited from it were us he did too I
mean it was good for all of us but but
you ignored what it did for me I have no
idea where I do without it I have no
idea because someone's gotta happen to
make you famous just like it did you you
know all this callus happen for you way
before it happened for me and that with
all his perpetual motion that had these
all these things that happened that
prevailed you to where you were to stay
where every College in the country
wanted to be you you know that's and so
something's got to happen to make that
happen her it doesn't happen so that was
what happened for us you know that's
what happened for me that's what made me
famous was blue-collar one sold four
million [ __ ] dvds and I couldn't go
into a [ __ ] Walmart without him you
know just of being mobbed and I'm away
less famous now than I was ten years ago
you think so oh I know something because
when that album came out and then the
next one sold four million to their you
know when a family I'm comes out even
more than musically I'm a people share
with each other and I used and I know
that's true because I was such a big
Steve Martin fan back in the day that I
had let's get small with me all the time
and played it for everybody i saw
literally if even if I didn't know you I
go hey listen this and then I would take
credit for a [ __ ] great was you know
it cuz I just liked it so much I mean
ladies was such great out and so uh
oh thank you it's more whiskey yeah well
we're jokela mmm got one more coffee all
right goddamn a naval lead Olivia
newton-john drinks like a fish does she
really does she drink she did they find
her husband yeah yeah no they Jing her
husband cuz i was playing in australia
when that her husband like disappeared I
guess he was here tonight oh he was okay
some strange mysterious story nobody
else knows that oh yeah it now I can
remember it this must not be that
husband cuz some of the guy um disappear
maybe it is the guy I don't know maybe
bumped his head and was wandering around
the desert in Australia well you know
you like to think of it um no I do Oh
back to what were we talking about it I
was lost anything back to the book thing
what's your favorite book of all time
yeah you know what Tahoe several you
know as far as just a great [ __ ] read
that ever play with a book that i had
laying around my house that i'll just
pick up and read passages of it like it
was a bible is a river runs through it i
think is the most beautiful piece of
literature I've ever read and you know
you really walk away from that book just
seeing everything that that he saw his
entire life and so in the mood near here
in the movie even though the movie was
part of two different books this is also
very well done by Robert Redford you
know and I'm totally queer for Brad Pitt
especially in that movie and legends of
the fall you know who legends look
heartstrings I wouldn't be mouth to this
yeah totally so
the but anyway I gotta say if I had to
pick a book to the day if I was gonna
recommend somebody read a piece of
fiction that really wasn't fiction I
don't think and you know i would have to
pick that book a river runs through it
she busted with internet porn when he
was 15 and I felt so sorry for him she
called me just clock and Brock Brock and
I felt horrible for the kid goes when I
was 15 I was so horny I could jack off
to the Sears catalog and that's just big
girl panties and lawn mowers I can't
imagine me in 15 years old and having an
unstoppable stream of pornography piped
straight into your goddamn bedroom when
I was a kid I had to earn porn man you
had to wait till your friend's dad went
out of town on business you had to pull
down a rickety spring-loaded attic
ladder you to crawl up into a dusty
spider rhythm [ __ ] crawlspace pours
through cardboard boxes till you find an
eight millimeter real then what learn
how to work a [ __ ] projector that's
what
and after all that you got silent bushy
born and if there was a soundtrack it
was always so [ __ ] up you couldn't
understand it oh we talked about that
Cuomo imma be me because think his
finger in her ear know his penis in her
rear watch the movie we had one friend
there was two years younger than us and
he went she put it in her mouth
I didn't know she was gonna put it in
her mouth she gonna need the brush her
teeth not yet but she will watch the
film
note to self put it in her mouth so
Laurie told me she goes that's my
ex-wife's name is because you're going
to need to talk to your son about sex
it's time and I said well you're right
it is if she goes when are you gonna do
it run a city is gonna be at the house
this weekend so I'll talk to him in and
said okay fine I said Marcia turn off
television turn it off I need to talk to
you all right said I want to talk to you
about sex yes Oh dad come on certain
help you're 15 years old it's time we
had this talk and he goes okay I said
the clitoris is as sensitive as an
eyeball
sat it that's all I got don't go over up
and owners if it's dry turn that TV back
on boy what about safe sex daddy is
never safe to her husband's always come
home that's a [ __ ] men your son 12
graduated from college in Orlando where
do you go ucf no he went to a college
called full sail which is a media school
yeah well with a degree in recording
arts cool my sister used to do the
import orientation there for many years
right it's a physically agree that you
can work at Starbucks with or wherever
you want my son says kratom that's what
he does what that kratom is a it's a
it's a herb that's grown in Indonesia
it's gonna kind of the coffee plant
thing it's really great okay it's like
imma be like a synthetic marijuana type
thing or it's not rough daddy go
completely organic yeah but it's not
like it's not like marijuana which says
a Titch more attached more like blow
then pop but by really not like either
one of them it's it's kind of a unique
buzz it's a it gives you more focus that
way show up you know like way more the
coffee would but not as much as a you
know a nymphetamine so you don't feel
the jittery [ __ ] buzz of any kind so
it's very popular and in that but if you
do a lot of it it's ascetic so you can
get
really days it's been around for just
the dawn of man of course because it's a
[ __ ] organic plant but it's spreading
in popularity throughout the [ __ ]
world it's been tell you in four states
but the arrest of them is legal and my
son sells a [ __ ] out of it and Dan does
a-you know does a great business his uh
his website is kind kratom calm his name
was Marshall and he would love to show
you your kratom if you're a kratom user
that's right you're the first person
ever to tell me about it you're really
outspoken proponent and consumer of
marijuana don't you find it interesting
that right after the Occupy Wall Street
movement it was shortly after that that
state started to like loosen up the
marijuana laws i mean i think that
there's some kind of connection maybe
the government like ah if we you know
give these people we'd write me they
won't let me go call the [ __ ] yeah so
we're right reasonable you know free
[ __ ] remember I don't know you know
it's up there the thing is the problem
the problem with you know hot you know
whether you smoke pot or no smoke pot
really doesn't matter at all you know I
would say that if you don't smoke pot
don't start smoking pot that is well
that's what I would tell you I mean
there's really no sense in it it's very
expensive there's no upside to it really
except for me you know creatively I like
it and it helps Mike with my attention
deficit disorder and it also helps me
with my [ __ ] xanex problem that uh
with pot I could kind of control that
and my doctors and I have decided well
you know what I've I've made a deal with
my demons and in the deal is that if I
cut them off altogether they'll burn
down the house
I with me in it so with that being said
we realized there has to be a compromise
of some sort which I was trying to
manage my own way with my own
connections so it ended up being
handfuls of these pills and those pills
and you know wellbutrin and all these
things so now even though i still take
[ __ ] handfuls pills but but but none
of them are big [ __ ] barbiturates you
know so now the pot you know an idea and
I'd take edibles but if it it's just
such an amazing lead the arguments are
for it or is that are just they're just
so stupefyingly dunk that it's hard to
even [ __ ] talk about it you know they
talked about on stage name is really the
first night I ever said these words was
all you have to do is think about two
numbers alcohol-related deaths
marijuana-related death one of them
eight hundred and ninety-five thousand
and one of them seven well that's the
exit at what you see those two numbers
the case is closed right we go okay well
then yeah that wasn't II that was
nothing wrong with that one this was the
one we ought to be looking at right so
but that made the one we're looking at
we're looking to the other one no oh no
no no there look at this little problem
right here this mare wasn't the right
there this one over here that's nothing
after the drum Lambeth and a wheel an
automobile what there's nothing I didn't
make pot smoker my whole life I'm pretty
surprised I never thought this country
would go the way that it's gone you know
it had to you know eventually because
you know here's the thing you know what
causes changed death old people that
[ __ ] have stupid [ __ ] ideas that
they're hung up on died they have God
thank God they [ __ ] died and then
progress gets made by younger people
with new ideas they go went wait a
minute they were lying to us did you
know the [ __ ] that even Willie Nelson
in that book talked about the early
marijuana movies the you know what was
that early marijuana movie about matauri
for memory reason why I was right I
walked it as a kid and like [ __ ] I never
later ragtime piano when I was hot guy
like play the piano and he's all like
looking crazy and smoking it it's a
brilliant point that older people die
with these [ __ ] up / in song life
moves on I mean the big does a beautiful
McKinley who we talked about earlier
does a beautiful bit about his
grandfather being racist and it's a new
piece that he's doing that is really
[ __ ] good he's closing with it and
about how he tried to change his
grandfather's who how he's embarrassed
as a young guy from Alabama that was
very progressive to have a racist
grandfather and it's a beautiful [ __ ]
piece of comedy that's so [ __ ] brave
and important that you know that well
I'm not going to talk or time I try to
do it for you but you know if you ever
have a chance to hear it it's a 13
chicanery what is the greatest joke you
think that you've ever written you know
maybe you know I did a pretty long piece
on Tiger Woods defending Tiger Woods
that was really funny that was one of
the hardest bits I've ever had to quit
doing you know it all that [ __ ] I've
had to quit doing you know I but that's
that that's the thing I'm that I look at
I gotta quit doing it so what is what is
the time frame I mean like give film a
DVD special and then right well tire it
i mean i doin you know Donny and Marie
for Hawaiian Punch and I was having a
[ __ ] okay you may do in the big so it
was just you know is just a have a feel
for what for with my show because I
because I play these towns I mean I I
toward like crazy so I'm back in these
towns every two and a half years so I
want to be there with another show and
that's how long it takes me to write it
so so I got to drop it and I got to put
something else in so and I but with that
the tiger would fit was uh was i felt
like one of the best things I've ever
done it was and it'll be hard to let it
go and and I just did a tour in Canada
and I knew they didn't have that record
up there and so I did it I brought it
back up and did it was fun as [ __ ] to do
and it was killing when I dropped it i'm
just like--that's guy got quit doing it
any but it was murder then and it was
basically the bid was the tiger didn't
get any credit for all that [ __ ] turned
down hahaha that was the crux of it and
my last best friend her asthma cheated
on her and my wife hates Tigers guess
I'm like what about that guy you don't
hate that guy he did at one time he had
one chance Tiger was 18 for 82,000 I
takes a little goddamn discipline right
there if 82,000 women want to have sex
with you and you only [ __ ] hate team a
little mess haha love he was in love
with that woman but it was a 20 minute
long bit though but that was the crux of
it so having one of my favorites do you
like and you you work in new material
and chunks I mean or because I mean you
got to deliver the goods as a headliner
as well right so you can't go out there
into a whole new hour no I'm ever do
never do i go i change my ex one joke at
a time and i also do a ton of open mic
you know like i do whenever I'm not
honest I i I'm a comic every diet of my
life so when I'm not doing Big Show's
I'm doing little shows every night not
just some of the nights every night I go
on stay somewhere and do something you
know I'm working on something trying to
twist up something and so get them it's
not part time for me it's a it's every
night and any you know any really
relevant you know comical tell you you
know if you're not gonna stay Jerry you
know every chance you can get near
microphone than food [ __ ] you yeah
it's like being a boxer man you can't
right the muscles get flabby notion that
you got to be in the jail you can't come
back you know you've seen a lot of guys
get away from comedy to try to kick back
a new yeah exactly one of the most I
think one of the most important things
that ever happened to me was I was on my
couch had made millions of dollars and
lazy fat smoking weed my house in
Atlanta on a golf course my dream and in
dance Miller's HBO specials coming on
and he lives in Montecito where I've
just bought a house and this special is
so [ __ ] bad that I get off my couch
haha and get my car and drive me and do
is set a little down right here if I
don't
do we show some way i did that i have
deals he didn't smell too late for that
thank you i love you do this I really do
he's a great guy I do love you can't
take any one of my favorite comic for a
long time yeah you can't take 20 years
off no no and then just have him say wha
give you being bug okay literally he's
reading it you could see reading it well
and oh my god I can't take him anytime I
was taking a month off I I lose it
completely what is the greatest advice
you've ever been given as a comedian put
the punch line at the end of the joke
Jeff bought for the first day I was ever
in the business really what he said he'd
go to your man he was he was in my first
show he was a headline the comedy club i
started in denial and he and he was
there there were three i think there
were three funny bones in that area that
one dallas won in arlington and he was
just doing the three-run thing so he
came out talking like that and he's on
my first set ever and he comes up to me
and wepartee well I thought and he comes
up to me afterwards that he goes uh he
goes man you're really funny but you
need to put the punch line at the end of
the joke oh well how do you do that so
let's have generously guys he's just
down with a brand new comic the comic
there's done once that is [ __ ] life
has four minutes of material total you
add it all up it adds up to four [ __ ]
minutes and two of them don't work and
he said he goes ok so now he writes it
out on paper so we all right here's what
you're saying that right right right
he's more interested in it than I am
right it out of here you go there you go
there so if you say that here there now
you save this and then the punch line is
really this not this that's the bunch
line and then you say this and then you
just stare out and they will [ __ ]
and alive it's fun huh in that box work
box where my mentor he taught me how to
write jokes talk me how to do jokes
toppy have deliver joke taught me how to
get famous tell me how to sell make
money did you get the famous huh how did
he teach you to get famous well you were
actually just did it for me you know he
just did all the work he did it for me
but but he also gave me great advice to
you know he said when blue collar one he
actually handed me the DVD for blue
collar one which nobody had ever seen
and he had gotten a copy of it and and
it was good and intestine is HEIs
forrest gump with every age group and he
hands it to him and he goes this is
going to make you famous do something
for me be nice to everybody well as it
[ __ ] Jack dog [ __ ] oh y'all Rowdies
classic Rana I love you I respect you
and it's great to you know meet you
properly in closing is there any words
of wisdom or advice that you have for
the people of the earth you know be nice
to everybody and I thought of that
myself that's an original thing I came
up with jeff says I stole it from him
but I didn't I thought of it first and
then I gave it to him then he gave it
back to me and I gave it back to him and
he passed it back and forth an idea over
the years be nice to each other be nice
to each other that's fun that's what we
are my camp were nice to each other
we're not to each other yeah and you're
not aureus for being you know great to
comedians I mean I know everybody that
works for you is the female Clint as
sensitive as human eyeball yeah I think
there's really something to do that if
you treat it like it's an eyeball you
won't just go stabbing your thumb on it
without making sure it's winking at one
time before you go haha I think it's
solid advice you know I do I don't know
Margo likes it she's glad I 32 like it's
an eyeball that's great thanks for
making the world a better place run long
may you run brother Thank You Man long
mayor
nancy boy too just bout to insane
I've been down
the picture plane
jumping on
far away that I feel
make me stay
don't give it away
No
I've been sitting by the fire
one and where my school
look it through the mail
I try to find out
which way the wind blows
hello come on
for the period
you got to go
now before you give
don't care
buh-bingo
bingo
Oh
down
I
I'm going with [ __ ]
talk to and
Oh
go kami
No
Oh
and trust it
I've got to go
make my way
I'm i can return
Oh
goddammit
to get mixed up
the girl
don't get me too
muggins here
I